hey what's up everybody to kick off
season four we are going on the road to
search for the greatest voices across
America
we're going Coast to Coast top to bottom
y'all and we're traveling on our
kellyoke bus and fans can sing a virtual
duet with moi
[Music]
tiktok using the hashtag
search I
decided we're gonna have so much fun
let's go
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and the first stop is New York City
[Music]
hey everyone my name is Josh Sutherland
I'm gonna be the director on the road
with the Kelly search let me show you
the tour bus come on
[Music]
the
show
oh my God I love this oh my gosh is this
like what I think it is
did the 90s just make their way back
into my heart am I taking this I'm
taking it oh this is where they're
performed you're probably nervous and
they go I mean I'm a professional singer
and I'm a little odd right here so I'm
like
I'm not just doing a virtual duet with
Kelly Clarkson like what is happening
right now
[Music]
okay I want to see this footage let's go
check it out
[Music]
[Applause]
I can't breathe
are you okay
welcome to karaoke search
[Applause]
my friend was on the Kelly Clarkson team
on The Voice and she could not stop
talking about like how beautiful inside
now Kelly was and I was like of course
it's not it's not a surprise so I love
you okay okay
experience created just for you
um are you ready to sing with me well
it's done let's go
God
[Music]
hey I can't breathe for the first time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh no okay oh no oh no we're so we were
literally just watching the whole time
boy we love her just your personality
nice to meet you beautiful inside oh my
God I don't know oh you're so nice wait
and your voice is so good have you
always been singing yeah I'm not saying
like acapella groups and stuff but
trying to do my own thing now I love you
oh my gosh thank you so much for doing
this thank you
[Music]
I'm a huge Kelly fan ever since American
Idol Haley is Iconic I've been a fan
since 0-2 she's the girl that can sing
down and I love a girl who can sing down
so I'm a fan
[Applause]
yeah he's awesome
so wait have you always been a singer
you're a crazy great singer my whole
life grew up in church singing musical
theater and now I'm in New York on
Broadway oh my God can I hear a little
bit more of your voice
Unbreak My Heart
say you love me again
come on Tony yeah foreign
[Music]
okay everybody today has been amazing
here in New York City as we thought it
would be so we are off right now to go
shoot the premiere week our first
premier week here in New York City we
loved it last season I cannot wait to do
it this season we have some surprises
it's gonna be amazing next stop for
Kelly okay search is shy town
[Music]
I know y'all got some good singers here
let's do it
[Applause]
[Music]
you want biscuits and chicken it's all
for you
I love Chicago
I am here to sing a duet with Kelly
Clarkson I'm ready to rock and roll are
you ready I'm so ready you're ready
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
she's good let's go say hi to Sandy I
like Sandy
my gosh you came on the screen I was
like wait I know her how are you oh good
how are you I'm so good
so good I've been good I just got off a
Broadway tour oh my congratulations
congratulations thank you what was the
show a Jesus Christ Superstar oh my gosh
that's so cool thank you I want you to
show them something else other than that
song you want to say something else yeah
absolutely you guys know her tonight
yeah in the public oh yeah I know that
too
yeah
so I'll hit the lights and if you lock
the door
when I'm leaving this room till we both
feel more
so don't walk away don't roll yourself
[Music]
tonight
oh my gosh amazing thank you for coming
thank you oh my God that was so good
Sandy
here to sing with Kelly Clarkson
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
as soon as you're doing the harmony
stuff oh yeah okay Harmony all right I
love your voice harmonies thank you what
do you do for a living I actually work
for a major airline I'm a gay agent I
actually sing to all of the passengers
yeah when they board the plane and I
made my own jingle wait did you sing to
them wait will you sing some I want to
hear the jingle yeah my name is AJ and I
thank you for flying with Southwest
we've gotten on time flight to board so
you know you're flying with the best if
you got a drink that's cool gotta snack
by it so stick with us we aim to please
but if you've got alcohol don't you take
it on board but you can leave your drink
with me
nice to meet you AJ
[Music]
it was amazing oh my gosh
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you so much
all right so next up next up Dallas yeah
we are going to Dallas Texas my home
state I'm very excited I know there's a
lot of great singers there so I cannot
wait for the karaoke search to continue
[Music]
we're in Texas today one of my favorite
places to visit
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
just made it to Dallas Texas I am
certain we will find amazing singers
here Texas is full of us I'm just saying
but let's go check it out
[Music]
I can't believe I'm about to sing with
Kelly Clarkson
so Kelly and I met and performed
together 20 years ago at Six Flags
here's a picture and this opportunity
would sort of be the the reuniting of
both of us to perform together again
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm super excited I'm ready let's do
this
let's see what you got it
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
anyways
[Applause]
oh I want to hear her sing together
let's go see her all right all right oh
my gosh
we're both sweaty yeah we were both in
the same like color yeah so wait how
long have you been singing ah since I
was six years old wow I actually wanted
to give up at one point I didn't even
want to do it anymore yeah um I had lost
my brother to Suicide oh my God yeah but
people came up to me was like you can't
give up you can't quit like your voice
is a message to other people and you
have to keep going so I want to hear you
sing something else because since you've
been gone it's a fun song to Belt what
else what else could you do baby
[Music]
tell me
thank you so much
I appreciate it
[Music]
thank you
to Dallas I knew that you would deliver
some incredible Talent we have heard so
many great voices today
[Applause]
we were so stoked about it um it is time
though to get back on the bus I think it
was one more stop here we come
all right we're coming for you la
unch
there's no better place to end this
karaoke search than where we first began
here in Los Angeles I cannot wait to
hear y'all sing let's do it
[Music]
party Universal Studios Hollywood okay
here we go all right let's go let's see
what you got
so big
[Music]
for the first time
[Applause]
[Music]
you hear Broadway in there yeah yeah
serious Broadway all right let's go see
him
we just heard you so I have to say do
you have like some sort of Broadway
background I do okay because I was like
we were kind of hearing it we like it
thank you I feel like you look familiar
well I have been plaguing the internet
um with videos Wishing you a good day
for the past 10 weeks
just something simple like that I don't
know
[Music]
[Applause]
Ellie hope you have a good day but I
want to hear more of your voice so what
what would you like to sing that that
isn't mine and you can tell everybody
this is your song
it may be quite simple but
now that it's time
I hope you don't mind I hope you don't
mind that I put down in words
how wonderful life is
now you're in the world your vibrato is
beautiful thank you I mean is that a
good answer to God but it was beautiful
thank you oh my God
if you see me singing it's definitely a
karaoke song but never with a celebrity
so it's something new I'm super excited
the wedding with Kelly is literally my
dream so I'm very second
let's go Kelly
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that was amazing but what if you were
gonna pick a song to sing for us that
wasn't that yes what would that be
this keep on turning
I'll never keep on burning
rolling rolling rolling down a river
[Music]
so much yes
[Applause]
that was incredible it was great that
was so much fun
all right everybody so this wraps up our
karaoke search or our karaoke tour
rather we rolled from one town to the
next bringing people together through
music
[Applause]
we heard some great performances along
the way as well
[Music]
[Applause]
in fact there were a handful of
performances that we love so much we
decided to bring those singers back to
Los Angeles for a very special surprise
I'm just gonna let you know that y'all
had some of my favorite performances
from the karaoke search and I want all
of you to come to Los Angeles to perform
with me on my show oh my God
oh
in addition to those four cities there
was another part to our kellyoke search
Tick Tock and from all of those tick
tocks you posted we had one more
favorite performance and one more singer
to surprise
hello
oh my gosh what's up for shark
surprise wow the reason why
um I'm here is because I have loved a
lot of the videos that were sent in from
Tick Tock there are a lot of great
singers for the Kelly research but
I saw yours and guess what
you're one of my favorite performances
that I watch and I want you to come to
Los Angeles I want you to sing with me
yeah
having somebody finally see and be like
hey you're good enough like that means
so much like you don't man you don't
understand how much that means to me
[Applause]
this ready to perform with me on the
show I'm so excited I'm so excited oh
I'm I'm beyond ready like I'm I'm ready
to go it's going to be something special
y'all
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]